Today seems like a quieter day for
what's happening between Iran and the
United States. Of course, Iran is now
claiming that uh tankers, two of them
have been hit by a sea mine and they are
on fire and disabled. Of course, there's
no cooperation or or denial at this
point from Sentcom or the United States
side. So, it could be Iranian
propaganda. But on the topic of
propaganda, I think it's really
important we understand what Donald
Trump just truthd out because Donald
Trump just told us, "Hey boys and girls,
it is officially time, much like we've
done with Lake Ontario, much like we've
done with the Gulf of Mexico, now called
the Gulf of America." Donald Trump
suggests it is now officially time to
rename the Strait of Hormuz
Trump Strait. Uh this seems to be sort
of his tendency, especially since now
even an airport in West Palm Beach is
the Trump airport. But here you go. Now
that we have it under USA control,
should we change the name Hormuz Strait
to Trump Strait? Like America itself, it
would be hotter than ever before. Thank
you for your attention to this matter,
President Donald J. Trump. And then of
course, you know, they're like, "Yeah,
raw raw raw, go America." But is it go
America? After all, here's the
commentary that we're getting from uh
not only people concerned about what
Saudi Arabia is up to, but also what
concern there is with what Iran is
either plotting or potentially has up
its sleeves. Let's take a look at this.
So, uh, the first thing we have is this
is the note right here from Alazer. The
IRGC says two oil tankers exploded after
hitting a mine and are now on fire.
Again, we don't have a way to
corroborate this, uh, which is
unfortunate, but we'll we'll see. We'll
keep paying attention to this. This is
where we have the commentary from Alazer
on Trump renaming the strait, which
obviously we just saw directly on Truth
Social. But the greater concern is right
here that Iran's Supreme National
Security Council uh and one of the
members on it has pledged that the
United States will soon witness Iran's
quote new strategy for war after recent
strikes. With these flailing efforts,
not only will you not emerge from the
hell you've created for yourself, but
you will s soon see Iran's new strategy
on the battlefield in diplomacy and
confronting the economic blockade that
will shatter your foundations. So, why
would Iran be talking about shattering
foundations of the United States? Well,
one of the things we talked about
yesterday, especially now following the
strikes we saw yesterday, which the
death toll for has risen to 19 in
various different areas, including where
that wedding was struck, where it was
believed four people were killed and
about 35 were injured. And then you've
got various different regions listed on
screen here where there were other
deaths uh tallied up from the US
strikes. But Iran is basically now
saying, "Look, we kind of see now how
you guys attack us and how you're going
to go for us. We're going to quote
unquote forcefully attack y'all relying
on our missile and drone capabilities
and respond to your movements." But how
are we going to do it? And that's the
interesting part is two ways. One, Iran
believes they can continue to use this
castle breaker missile. They've already
been using this. This is how they allege
they've been able to break through some
of the interceptors that have been used
even in Jordan or in other areas where
some of these ballistic missiles are
hitting their targets and that obviously
isn't ideal for the United States when
some of these sort of break through and
they're either breaking through because
they've got better uh a faster speed,
the United States can't prepare quickly
enough or there's a miscalculation that
says, "Hey, we'll let that one slide
because it's going to land where there
was nothing and then all of a sudden
last moment uh some of these can rapidly
change trajectory and then ending up uh
and can then end up hitting uh a target
that the United States may not have
expected would end up getting hit. This
is how we've seen some of our aircraft
uh destroyed like some of our Century
aircraft uh or other aircraft damaged
and destroyed from missiles that have
gotten through or drones that have
gotten through.
The big concern that a lot of folks have
right now isn't with the IAEA
suggesting, hey, we don't know where all
the nuclear material is. This is a
concern. We already know that. We've
been talking about that Pickax Mountain.
The IAEA concerned about this fourth
nuclear facility that Iran has announced
as an enrichment facility, but they've
never had access to. These are all
problematic. The bigger concern would be
is Iran potentially going to try to
attack the heart of that blockade by
using
new missiles or new equipment
potentially in partnership with Russia
that they haven't used before. This is
something that we've been analyzing over
the last 24 hours. Uh, and even though
things seem cooler today, it does make
you question, as Donald Trump argues, we
have full control over the Straight of
Hormuz. And Iran claims they're mining
and blowing up ships in the straight of
Hormuz, which in fairness, Monday
evening, they did end up targeting two
tankers. Could this situation rapidly
escalate if they start using a
supersonic cruise missile or some form
of weaponry they haven't used before?
You would presume that they would have
already pulled those stops at this
point, but then it depends on the
development cycles. So this remains a
risk with this war in Iran kind of
continuing and Donald Trump feeling like
he's won. Donald Trump says, "Hey, it's
in complete control. The US has won. You
know, what's there to worry about?"
Well, maybe some new weaponry is
essentially the enemy adapts. Now, the
US is also arguing that we have a new
policy called a tanker fortanker policy
when it comes to uh attacking Iranian
oil. And what I've noticed in just the
last hour is that oil prices have
actually started rising again. So as we
saw uh these attacks yesterday, oil
quickly ran up to about $945 a barrel.
That did relax a little bit this morning
and we actually fell back into the 94
range. But you'll notice here following
these escalator this escalatory
commentary that Trump wants to rename
the straight of horror moves and Iran uh
is you know prepping to unleash new
forms of weaponry. We've got oil back at
9558. Not ideal especially since we're
following this new what's called tanker
fortanker policy. Okay so what is the
tanker fortanker policy? Basically this
is a policy where uh when two US tankers
are hit uh which uh I guess they weren't
US tankers. We had one uh Sri Lankan
registered uh South Korean ship uh South
Korean company Sri Lankan registered and
then we had a Saudi ship. Both of these
were struck uh Monday evening trying to
get through that passage that Donald
Trump always talks about which is the uh
southern passage along the northern
portion of the Omani coast, southern
portion of the straight formoose. Two
ships were hit there. There is a concern
that either Iran is using newer
targeting methods or they're potentially
getting better at sneaking drones and
rocket fire through the US not only
blockade but protective shield for those
ships. Two ships did get struck and that
was acknowledged by the United States.
Now, we don't know about the two extra
ships that were potentially mined, but
here's the new strategy. per Axios and a
US official who spoke to Axios on this.
Uh and and this is normal that this
stuff leaks because they're trying to,
you know, boast this in front of Iran
via the media. Uh so that what they're
trying to do is dissuade Iran from
attacking US tankers because apparently
the new policy is, hey, if you attack
two of our tankers, then we are going to
attack two of your tankers. So remember
Monday night, two tankers were hit by
rocket fire and drones as they were
transiting under our military shield. So
some form of failure obviously happened
here. And what do we have right here?
The US military attacked two Iranian
government tankers as part of the round
of strikes that took place on Tuesday.
This is the first time the US military
has struck Iranian tankers in the region
for retaliation against uh uh you know
the these attacks.
So, not ideal. Donald Trump claiming
victory. But on the other hand, we're
also now targeting tankers. We're
posting images or video clips of us
targeting tankers and Iran, which you
know, they could talk a big talk, but in
fairness, they keep sneaking bombs
through our so-called shields. This new
tanker for tanker strategy suggests we
could end up having higher oil prices
for a lot longer. And the worstc case
scenario going forward is that Donald
Trump is branding that at $95 per barrel
for Brent, Donald Trump is branding, oh,
we have total and complete control of
Hormuse, guys, there's nothing to worry
about. And then what ends up happening
is we end up getting hit with some type
of cruise missile that was in part
developed with Russia or some targeting
that China aided them with. and you end
up getting this piece in Hormuz or the
straight of Trump or whatever you want
to call it, the Trump straight uh gets
disrupted even more and then we're back
to three figure oil for Brent. That's
the big risk right now. Uh see, take a
look at this. Alazer, rightfully so,
just one minute ago posting here. It's
been less than a week since Sentcom
announced it cleared the straight of
Hormuz of any mines and Donald Trump
brags about there being a free flow of
shipping. Yet all of a sudden now the
IRG is claiming they just got, you know,
ended up targeting two more ships with
mines. And we did see ships confirmed on
both sides. We did see two ships struck
on Monday. So this idea that oh, it's
totally open. Not that great. Reports
suggest telecommunication tower located
near site a fatal US wedding attack.
Yeah, a lot of people were wondering why
did the United States target a wedding
on a residential building. Uh, and
apparently there's no verification of
whether the building was deliberately
targeted or if it was collateral damage.
But some reports are suggesting that a
telecommunications tower located nearby
was the target. Uh, but this also sort
of raises questions around like how did
we previously also accidentally hit a
little girl school uh with a cruise
missile? Like do do we not have are we
not paying Palunteer enough data or is
our underlying data not strong enough?
It's obviously, you know, a very
sensitive topic, but your mistakes on
civilians obviously shouldn't happen.
Those mistakes give Iran a lot of
propaganda potential, and that's another
big thing to consider here. Donald Trump
mentioned uh in a truth social, I think
it was last night, uh anyway, somewhere
he was basically trying to talk about
when are the Oh, here it is. Here it is.
I found it. I'm not trying to force Iran
to the bargaining table as ABC fake news
reported. I could care less if they
signed a worthless to them agreement. I
like our position now in the straight.
Their economy is totally collapsing. In
fairness, their realale is now at a new
low. $1 buys 2.2 million Iranian
realale. Okay, that's really bad. So
yes, you are seeing massive economic
pain. But when you see this commentary
here, Donald Trump's like, "Hey," he
ends this as like, "When are the Iranian
people going to rise up and fight?"
Well, it's probably
impossible for people to rise up and
fight uh because you're in this nasty
position of just not having even enough
money to put put food on the table. So,
you're sort of relying on central
planning just to be able to get by and
survive because you're experiencing so
much inflation. So, your only option is
to sort of rely on the government unless
you essentially want to perish and and
starve. Is a really problematic
situation. I'm not saying everybody's
starving in Iran. you know, some things
are attempting to be business as normal
in Iran. But
I think Trump, you know, really launched
this war February 28th intentionally to
try to latch on to the uprising that was
already occurring in December. It
unfortunately faded before Donald Trump
strikes for his purposes. And now we're
kind of left with this quagmire of the
straight of Hormuz where we're we just
have Iran dangling this threat of hey we
got new weaponry coming.
Whether it does or doesn't we don't
know. That could all be propaganda. This
talk about them mining the straight
could all be propaganda. But it's
frankly the same propaganda that they're
going to use against America with
attacking civilians whether accidentally
or intentionally or whatever. uh and and
then you have this constant threat of
what's going to come out of Russia and
China. So this issue in terms of aiding
Iran, this issue is going to continue
for a while. There's also uh talk that
Chinese uh commercial vessels, so you
know, transporting containers
essentially are uh being used to help
Iran spy on the positions of uh US
intelligence in sort of a a hidden
manner, if you will. This is not to be
unexpected. Os Defender had a piece on
this. I thought it was pretty good. Uh
they're reporting the Reuter story that
says China stateowned shipping giant
Costco, not to be confused with the
company in America called Costco,
it sounds very similar when you say it
too fast, has used concealed equipment
aboard its vessels for decades to
connect uh to collect signals
intelligence for Beijing.
The officials suggest the systems can
collect comms from military aircraft and
vessels in North America, Europe, and
Asia, as well as information on military
communications technology, encryption,
and key maritime threats. Basically,
think of container ships, Chinese
container container ships, as being
these little vessels that could just
collect data everywhere, send it to the
Chinese military, which then it could
hand on a silver platter to Iran, which
they have done historically, uh whether
it's satellite data or or other
targeting data.
H. So, it's a mess. It's a quagmire. But
all we know is between now and then, oil
up and Donald Trump is focused on
putting his name on the straight of
Hormuz. I really kind of, you know, grew
accustomed to the name Hormuz because I
still think that when peace comes to the
region one day, we need to brand the
company Hormuz Booze Cruise.
Okay, that's a real business opportunity
right there. Like that's that's the next
startup. We all got to get in on that
one together. We all got to get a board
on that one. Anyway, that's Iran.
>> Why not advertise these things that you
told us here? I feel like nobody else
knows about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you. Kevin Praath there, financial
analyst and YouTuber. Meet Kevin. Always
great to get your take.